straight ahead on law and crime daily
laurie balodebo and her husband chad
accused of killing lori's fourth husband
to fulfill the religious prophecy did
the doomsday mom really think she was a
goddess who needed to rid the world of
zombies
and the britney spears conservatorship
the company appointed to assist her
finances
now asking to resign and a son taking a
stand against his own father
mark redwine my feelings were that he
just wasn't telling us everything he's
hiding something
the search and murder of 13 year old
dylan redwine plus
a mother crying out
as a former police officer is sentenced
to three years in prison for the fatal
shooting
of daniel hambrick mrs hamburg lost her
son that day
and i am responsible for her loss law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
new details in the so-called doomsday
cult couple saga
please now say chad dabell and lori
valodebel
believe lori's husband charles valo had
to die for them to fulfill
their religious prophecy valo and her
husband
chad daybell already faced charges in
the murders of valo's children
seven-year-old j.j valo and 16-year-old
tylie ryan
they're also accused of killing chad's
first wife tammy debell
now lori is charged with conspiring to
commit first-degree murder
in the death of her fourth husband
charles valo in june 2019.
police initially found laurie's brother
alex cox shot and killed charles in
self-defense
but after further investigation chandler
police say laurie conspired to kill
charles to fulfill a religious prophecy
and clear the way for her marriage to
chad dabell this 13-page report says
detectives found that lori valo
thought she was an exalted goddess and
she and chad were directed to lead
144 000 people in preparing for the end
of the world
they thought they could teleport call up
natural disasters and pray away demonic
spirits
records show charles vallo threatened to
tell tammy dabo about lori's
relationship with chad
less than two weeks later text messages
between lori and her brother
show lori asked alex to sleep at her
house while charles was in town
the next day charles was dead
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
gene a lot of people are going to ask
especially the defense if this goes to
trial
but if the case sounds so strong now why
would it take this long to go after
laurie
it's strong now because the prosecution
and the police officers and agents dug
dug
dug and slowly built a circumstantial
case
by use of text messages emails other
circumstantial evidence
if there's nothing there's nothing
remarkable about that it just takes time
to build a strong case when you don't
have any eyewitnesses
makes sense now terry does this whole
alleged ritual
sacrifice scream insanity defense from
the defense
or what else could they even say well
you know
it would scream insanity but the idaho
legislator in 1982
decided to repeal idaho's insanity
defense statute so they can't use
that they can use her mental condition
though to try to show
whether or not she had the mens rea as
you know the intent to actually commit
the crime
but i don't think they're going to be
able to use that as a defense
either because that indictment against
lori is
rather detailed it talks about phone
calls and text messages and emails
between
laurie val de bell and between alex and
between
zulina who is the wife of alex and so
i think that there is intent there and
the other thing is we know that charles
vallo was shot
twice now based on the indictment once
while he was lying
flat or at least that's the allegation
so that chose intent
yeah and terry what do you make about
the timing because right now lori
valodeva is found incompetent to stand
trial so how is that going to play into
this these charges well as you know they
will continue to see
whether or not she's competent she's
getting the treatment and it'll keep
getting extended every 90 days or so so
we'll see what happens
we'll see how the so-called exalted
goddess goes through this competency
hearing
or at least process sorry and see when
these cases start
thank you both and a new wrinkle in the
legal battles for britney spears as a
company that was going to manage her
money
alongside her father steps down
the 13-year saga for the britney spears
conservatorship
has taken another turn more than a week
after the singer's emotional courtroom
plea
the wealth management firm has asked to
leave the arrangement
bessemer trust cited the singer's
anguished comments to a judge
saying they have now become aware that
the conservative objects to the
continuance
of her conservatorship and desires to
terminate it
the company noted its role had not yet
taken effect and hasn't taken any action
this comes after the judge rejected
spear's request to remove her father
jamie spears
from her 60 million dollar estate he's
now requesting an evidentiary hearing
gene the more i learn about this case
the less i think anyone knows what
they're actually doing
how would you unravel this mess if you
were involved
well if i were the judge i would pick a
special master
to investigate and report back to me as
a judge
whether britney spears does have the uh
wherewithal to make a decision number
one
number two whether the father has the
experience
and the uh the objectivity to run her
estate
and whether they need a third party to
help both of them
uh from killing each other so that's
what i would do as a judge
all right so let me know when you run
for judge i'll make sure to vote in that
district gene
thank you and terry does it seem
alarming that the co-conservator was
brought on to help
was never formally assigned and is now
leaving because they realized their
appointment wasn't voluntary
i mean what does that say about the
state of this conservatorship
you know what it says is what i've been
saying all along which is
we really need to investigate what is
going on as far as the conservatorship
system is concerned
for there to be no communication between
the financial consultant which is the
bessemer trust
and brittany and her representatives
they
really needed to make sure that there
was a firm agreement
that everyone understood this was not
voluntary
and so i'm grateful that bessemer trust
is now
seeking to resign because now they know
it's not voluntary
but this should have been worked out
long before now
yeah this whole conservatorship for
britney spears seems as simple as my
last trip to the dmv
you go one way it doesn't work the other
way it doesn't work but hopefully we'll
keep eyes on this
saga and someone will straighten this
out i know many people are looking
to have britney spears freed thank you
both still ahead on law and crime daily
why a son is taking the stand against
his father for the murder of his younger
brother
plus emotions flying high in a nashville
courtroom
the mother begging a judge to reject a
plea deal for the
police officer who killed her son
[Music]
welcome back mark redwine's first wife
and oldest son
take the stand in his murder trial and
tell the jury about statements redwine
made after his youngest son disappeared
lawn crimes angenette levy is here with
their testimony that raised some
eyebrows
yeah brian brandon redwine and his
mother really recalled these statements
that seemed to fit with the
prosecution's theory of this case
over the objection of mark redwine's
attorneys
i figured mark knows something i didn't
know what he knew
i didn't know how we knew it brandon
redwine says his father's lack of action
and his words made him suspicious when
it came to dylan redwine's disappearance
he would talk to me about different
possible outcomes
like animal attacks or being shot by
hunters
and then he'd always go back to blunt
force trauma and it was just such a
distinctive
a different way of talking any other
time in fact brandon said he never
brought up blunt force trauma
and when his father brought it up in
2013 when some of dylan's remains were
found
his voice changed with him it was always
before his trauma
very direct and that always
like it got my attention on a very big
level
dylan's skull wasn't found until 2015.
a forensic anthropologist said it had
blunt force and sharp force injuries
that occurred near death
on cross-examination the defense brought
up other ways that mark redwine showed
concern for dylan
do you remember your dad discussing the
the pain he felt around thinking about
dylan somewhere
crying out for help and him not being
able to
respond he did make this come in brandon
redwine's mother and mark redwine's
first
wife said she became sick to her stomach
when she heard dylan was missing
and remembered something mark redwine
said in the late 80s
on a camping trip in the mountains he
had made a comment
that this would be a good place
to leave body horvath called the police
when she heard dylan was missing
his remains were found on middle
mountain seven months later
the defense questioning the statement's
relevance so we're talking about a
statement
over 30 years ago yes sir
an fbi cell phone analyst also testified
and said that he looked at the records
and mark redwine placed a call to dylan
the day after he disappeared and then
the day after that
placed another call but really that was
it there were not other phone calls in
which mark redwine was
really blowing up dylan's phone trying
to get a hold of him
that same analyst said that based on the
location of the cell towers he wouldn't
be able to tell
whether mark redwine's phone had been at
his home
or up on middle mountain where dylan's
remains were found
brian thanks antoinette let's bring back
former federal prosecutor gene rossi
and terry austin terry brandon redwine
seems to be the backbone of the
prosecution's theory
that mark's lack of concern is evidence
of guilt
the defense cross-examination shake any
of that idea at all
i think the defense did a decent job
there they made
some points mark expressed some concern
during his conversations with brandon
and i think the defense was able to show
that
he said he really was concerned that he
couldn't sleep
he said that he actually wanted to help
with the search but the authorities told
him
not to do that they encouraged him to
stay home so they did make
some points there the question is was
that concern genuine
and hopefully the jury will be able to
hear some of those calls because
we know that brandon did record some of
that
it'll be interesting to see whether or
not mark redwine takes the stand and
maybe explains
his action that may help the defense
gene this seems like a well-built
prosecution using circumstantial and
direct
evidence what do you think the
prosecution needs now to get that
verdict of guilty
they need to focus on the strong
evidence
and not present weak evidence this
comment made to his ex-wife he was
married to her in the 1980s for about
five years
he made a comment 30 years ago on a
vacation trip
when he was 29 years old stay away
from weak evidence that is weak to me
focus on the blood and the dna
in the pickup truck the rug all over the
house
then then also the timeline is important
and don't forget
motive the the vote the the photos that
the sun
corey found and also dylan uh those are
the things that are strong
focus on that gotcha and jeanette let's
go back to the forensic pathologist
testimony
what did she say caused the sharp force
injuries uh to dylan's skull
well dr dianne france testified that it
had to be
a knife of some sort or a sharp object
so she was really saying that that was
caused by something with
a bladed edge although she couldn't say
what knife or what kind of knife it
would have been
that's important because the prosecution
has or the defense rather has suggested
on several occasions that an animal
could have attacked dylan
uh and hurt him and killed him and then
dragged his remains and
obviously she was kind of pouring cold
water on that
defense theory of the case interesting
way i would say kind of cover that over
and thank you everyone for that
input coming up on law and crime daily
breaking down the charges against the
trump organization
and one of his top executives plus the
emotionally packed courtroom hearing
for a former cop pleading guilty to a
fatal shooting
a mother's strong words for her son's
killer still ahead
we're back and we're learning more about
the alleged 15-year scheme by the trump
organization
to commit tax fraud off the books
compensation
rent on a manhattan apartment lease
payments on the mercedes-benz and school
tuition
just some of the accusations against the
trump organization and his long-time
chief financial officer
alan weisselberg according to court
records weisselberg evaded taxes
on 1.7 million dollars of perks that
should have been reported prosecutors
say the company committed
a sweeping and audacious scheme to
defraud new york city
the state and the federal government
weisselberg and the company pled not
guilty to the 15 count indictment
former president trump released a
statement calling the charges a
political witch hunt
by radical left prosecutors michael
cohen trump's former personal lawyer
said the charges were just the tip of
the iceberg and more are expected to
come
let's bring back former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and co-host terry
austin
terry with these allegations being about
state and federal taxes
is there a chance federal charges could
be filed as well
well there is a slight chance i mean the
indictment did state that weisselberg
and the trump organization broke
city state and federal tax laws so
we could possibly see the doj
investigating this or the irs
taking it up as a place against you know
trump personally even
but i don't think that that's going to
happen i think there's no desire to
really get into that sort of detail and
i think what the
federal government is doing is waiting
to see what happens in the manhattan
da's office waiting to see
if in fact they can get the claims
against weisselberg and the trump
organization to stick
and if so then maybe they'll go after
them and maybe like i said they might
even
go after trump individually as well yeah
this could be the crack and the dam that
kind of has the
floodgates open up so to speak uh gene a
wise man once tweeted that the stormy
daniels deal
may be a part of the trial evidence can
you explain
yes pigs get fat hogs get slaughtered i
represented stormy daniels former
attorney
and in a matter involving the southern
district of new york and based on public
information not attorney client here's
what happened
michael cohen took out a loan 130 000
and went to stormy daniels
the trump organization reimbursed
michael cohen for that loan to the tune
of 400 000
so the net that he would pay after taxes
would be 130.
if the trump organization deducted that
400
000 as a business extent for legal
advice
that's criminal tax fraud so that could
pop up at the trial
we'll see how that plays out definitely
it seems like this trial could be dark
and stormy for the trump organization
and the legal roles for the former
president don't end there
senior investigative adam senior
investigative reporter adam klasseveld
spoke with the lawyer of the
whistleblower from trump's first
impeachment
about a man who was just sentenced to
prison for making death threats
he was indicted made the threat in
november of 2019 indicted in february of
2020
obviously covid and all hit pled guilty
i think in december of 2020
uh sentenced in june of 2021.
said something like i'm gonna bleed you
like
the pig you are uh i i we all
walk among you we know what you look
like we know who you
are you know you'll never see us coming
something
something like that interesting turn of
events when we come back
the sentencing hearing interrupted by a
mother's emotional plea
why deputies had to pull her away from
the defendant in the middle of the
courtroom
next
okay
don't don't fart anymore
[Applause]
don't come up here
chaos in the courtroom a mother lunging
for the defendant
telling a former police officer she can
never forgive him for the loss of her
son
the mother begged the judge not to
accept the plea deal for the former
officer
who now admits he was wrong for fatally
shooting her son
nashville police officer andrew delke
was on duty in july 2018
searching for stolen vehicles when he
noticed a white chevy impala driving in
an erratic pattern
officers followed the vehicle and
attempted to stop it before they said
the car
fled daniel hambrick ran and delky can
be seen on surveillance video
shooting hambrick multiple times in the
back ducky was scheduled to stand trial
but in a last-minute deal pled guilty to
voluntary manslaughter
pleading guilty today because i
recognize
that my use of deadly force was not
reasonably necessary
under all the circumstances
i
i recognize that what happened on july
26
2018 was tragic
mrs hambrick lost her son that day
and i am responsible for her loss
the victim's mother said she only
learned of the deal a day before
calling it quote racist bias and
implored the judge to reject it
so her son could get his day in court
the defendant and the judge were
escorted
out of the courtroom after a short pause
they returned and the judge accepted the
plea deal
and sentenced delky to three years
all right i find you guilty i find
there's a factual basis for them
and that the plea is freely and
voluntarily given
in case 2019 age 26
has sent us you to a term of three years
as a standard
range one offender that sentence is to
serve
there will be no petitions for further
release
gene three years for shooting a man in
the back was that enough
especially when the victim's family was
asking not to have the deal taken
you know who's the happiest person on
the planet right now
andrew delkey this is the sweetest of
sweetheart
deals he'll only serve about 18 months
i know people who sold a half a gram of
a half a gram of crack
and got more than andrew delke and
here's what bothers me the most
his statement is allocation to the judge
he didn't say that he had the intent he
was downplaying what he did
i would not have accepted this plea and
it is an
outrage what happened in this case yeah
i wasn't really seeing
the acceptance of what he did contrasted
with the actual penal law
i didn't see that admission there so i
agree with you there gene
terry your reaction to the powerful
words and actions
from the victims daniel hardberg's
family
well you can understand how his mother
felt in that moment in time
learning that in fact her son is not
going to get any sort of
retribution for his murder and that the
defendant is
only going to get three years he was
originally facing life in prison
for first degree murder and to plea it
down to manslaughter and get three years
and as gene said he'll be out before
that is really
not justice at all so she is angry and
she is displaying that anger
and the judge actually allowed her to do
it for quite some time until it became
apparent
that she was going to probably attack
the defendant and maybe even the judge
yeah and finding out what the plea deal
is the day before why a prosecutor do
that i have no idea
but gene terry thank you for joining us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you